some four million people have left
ukraine as the war with russia continues
many looking for sanctuary the response
has been swift by the west it makes
alfred melwatch proud to see the lengths
the canadian government is going to to
help people in need but it has also left
him with questions that is how they
should be responding um but we also got
to notice that
there's a lot of
ukrainian connection within the
government they're going to have a
better voice at the highest level than
other refugees for sure alfred fled
south sudan after civil war broke out
when he was nine years old he lived in a
kenyan refugee camp for more than a
decade before coming to canada in 2011
on a university scholarship
seeing the speed and options western
nations have made available for
ukrainians has been evident to some ngos
one human rights researcher says
european countries like poland have been
championed for their ability to bring in
the amount of people fleeing violence
but at the same time they have
introduced measures of blocking others
from entering the country helena cesar
with amnesty international says several
thousand syrian migrants are trapped on
the polish border with belarus after
that country looked to deport them and
poland refuses to grant the syrians
asylum on the border with ukraine
they're hailed as heroes they're
venerated
and on the other hand they are being
criminalized on this border
the syrian refugee crisis also pointed
to the willingness of western nations to
help the millions who were fleeing the
middle eastern country author serena
parekh says the ukrainian refugee model
is one that needs to be used in the
future so that
every refugee child can be greeted with
a stuffed animal and a chocolate bar
and not just the ones who are
quote-unquote like us
the visas ottawa made available for
ukrainians with canadian family are
flexible something that has never been
done before in a statement to global
news the immigration minister says the
country continues to resettle refugees
from around the world including the
middle east and north africa sean fraser
says quote we remain committed to the
refugee resettlement program and we will
continue to welcome refugees to canada
as conditions allow kyle benning global
news